ogres have layers onions have layers you
get it we both have layers I love the
idea of taking a fairy tale and turning
it on its head
and having it be that all the
traditional bad guys are good guys and
all the traditional good guys are bad
guys and I realized it's a dramatic roll
I mean halfway through I went there's an
emotional Center here you know the old
joke I wouldn't want to be a member of a
club that would have me as a member I
have always felt that way the concept of
going from a self-loathing ogre to a
self-accepting ogre was meaningful to me
I love you
I I love playing Shrek if I had to do it
one Shrek a year I'd be thrilled